this is a production of Cornell
University
all right Thank You Don is it's really a
pleasure to be here and as Don said I
was an undergraduate here and at the
opposite end of this hallway work
mounting herbarium specimens back in my
senior year is one of my jobs one of the
better jobs I had here is undergrad so
it's it's really nice to be back in this
building and relive memories of this
building so I have a lot to cover today
probably more than I I can cover but
we'll see how far we get today so what I
primarily want to talk about is so what
I want to talk about is the role of
Botanic Gardens that you may not think
of in terms of plant exploration and
plant introduction and so and give you a
the briefest of histories of the Morris
Arboretum but then get into some of the
work that I've done I'm really focusing
on China we do some collecting in the
United States as well and I'll if I have
time we'll finish with that but mainly
focus on China because it's exotic and
they're good stories about traveling in
China so all right
the Morris Arboretum was a was formerly
an estate John and Lydia Morris who were
siblings moved there in 1887 set up
their family estate or their country
home there and that's shown on the left
of this slide as you can see it was very
open at the time this was sort of out in
the country and this really was a
self-sustaining country estate they were
very interested in all sorts of things
they were interested in antiques plants
artwork and they collected plants as
well as lots of other things and this
shows the Rose Garden and the
conservatories back in the early 1930s
so since then the Arboretum has evolved
we are still a collection and we really
think of ourselves as the collections
based botanic garden but we embellish
the garden embellish the collections
with ornamentals so we're well known for
our rose garden is one of the things our
historic collection of trees and
philadelphia has a pretty ideal climate
it's sort of a sweet spot in terms of
growing trees and so some of the things
our big Katsura are the biggest of their
kind and certainly in eastern North
America as Dunn said we have a great
witch hazel collection one of my
interests
Magnolia's is something we've had a
long-standing interest in and then
maples as well and so all these are some
of the primary focuses but we have other
things we we grow as well so I'll give
you a 30 second you know plant
exploration history and a lot of people
think of the Golden Age of plant
exploration as the early nineteen
hundred's when people like eh Wilson
were collecting for first for Beach
nurseries in England and then for the
Arnold Arboretum in Boston and Wilson is
famous for lots of things including the
dove tree Davidian value krodha but
Wilson also had a strong horticultural
interest and later in his after he broke
his leg in China he was he travelled to
Japan which even then was you know
travel was a little easier in Japan
collected a lot of azalea Solo the
Kurumi azalea's the first introductions
were through Wilson and he was also
interested in flowering cherries which
is something that I think is long
forgotten about eh Wilson
and one of my great interests are
flowering cherries as well and so so
that's the early 1900s through World War
two China was still open to Westerners
so things like medicine Oya were able to
come out of China as it were this is our
big medicine oil grove at the Morris
Arboretum I should say we're four hours
pretty much due south of here so it's
not that hard to get to Philadelphia but
this is a probably a full zone warmer so
it feels like Nina always brings her
class down in April and they feel like
they've arrived in the tropics when they
come down there so please come down and
visit us so you know why do we go plant
exploring here's some of the reasons and
I won't read through these but I'll try
and touch on not all of these but many
of these today in my talk so back in the
late 70s the Arboretum identified
regions around the world that we would
target for plant exploration and some of
these seem obvious the eastern United
States
central China going up in
to Manchuria or northeastern China the
Korean Peninsula northern Japan what
what might be less obvious are the
Balkans and Asia Minor areas that have
similar climates to Philadelphia and
that yield you know plants a good
ornamental interest for us so those were
our goals in the late 70s here's where
we've gone since then in terms of plant
exploration trips and it's better seen
graphically on this slide and you can
see in purple are the target areas and
then the pins represent where we've gone
since then so we've really you know over
the last it's almost 30 years now really
set some goals and being able to
systematically achieve those goals so I
like to start out this talk with talking
about invasiveness because when I first
started giving this talk that was always
the first question that people ask do
you want to bring back invasives and of
course the answer is no so I start with
this and hopefully we'll you know dispel
that question so perhaps the sort of the
greatest example or a great example of
invasives that were planted with all you
know with great ideas and great
intentions is calorie pair or Pyrus
calorie ahna planted and promoted widely
in the you know in China in 1960s this
is one of the original plantings of
Bradford pear the scissors original
planting of Bradford pear in College
Park Maryland from the 1960s you know
great great tree look looks really good
here they are today and they've really
done well they were pruned well at the
beginning and they've held up really
well other than the powerlines on the
left and but we all know the problems
with calorie pare one is the weak
crotches and them splitting but I think
more importance from an ecological point
of view is the invasiveness and what's
happened is originally there was
basically one clone planted which is
self infertile subsequently additional
clones were planted so there's
outcrossing and fruit production so we
have one of these unfortunately in front
of our house my section my neighbor's
tree and those little fruits it's not
only are they annoying but they stain
the paint on your car which is doubly
annoying so if you were to drive a 90
five from Philadelphia to Washington
when the Yoshino cherries were in flower
this is what you would see and these are
not Yoshino cherries these are calorie
pairs and basically once you hit
Baltimore and from Baltimore to probably
at least Richmond this is what I 95
looks like the first third of April and
certainly we don't want to recreate this
we want them oh boy this wherever we can
so as plant explorers as Botanic Gardens
I think one of our roles is to evaluate
invasives and so I don't shy away from
it I think that's something we need to
embrace and think about and take on as a
role of Botanic Gardens so a little more
exciting than that is looking at
hardiness and vigor so you may think of
Philadelphia as being the banana Belt
but we really cannot grow camellias that
reliably in Philadelphia there were some
cold winters in the early 80s that wiped
out most of the collections of camellias
in Philadelphia and certainly in
Washington DC and from that arose a
program at the National Arboretum mainly
to do camellia breeding for hardiness
and you think of the camellia Belt
basically as Norfolk Virginia going down
the coast on the Gulf Coast and then
California up into the Pacific Northwest
so we're above what might be called the
camellia Belle
well with this in mind in the mid-80s
our director and some colleagues from
the National Arboretum and Longwood
Gardens went to a couple islands off the
coast of Korea these islands are above
the 38th parallel so it was politically
sensitive to go there and it's the
northernmost populations of camellia
japonica or the common camellia and here
are camellia japonica is growing on
those islands you can see you may be
able to see on the lower left there's a
person standing there so these get to be
small trees and they collected a large
number of seed from three islands there
these are single red flowered
communities not the highly ornamental
camellias but the the purpose of this
was to look for extending hardiness in
zone six so we planted out about 750 of
these starting in the late 80s after a
couple of winners this is
what they looked like and then from
those we called those and they're down
to about 50 plants from those original
750 those are now planted throughout the
Arboretum we subsequently did
evaluations of those and made four
selections from our plants one of which
is here on campus in the aisle our aisle
our quad so there is you know there was
shown to be extra hardiness in these and
so this is if you think about it the
selections were made around 2010 plants
were collected in 84 so this is a
generation of work and one of the
beauties of where I work and I think of
Botanic Gardens in general is you have
that long term horizon you're able to do
projects that take a whole generation -
so as I said nice glossy leaves single
red flowers and here are not just our
selections ours are the bottom for
balustrade Bloomfield Meadowbrook and
Morris Mercury and others that came out
of Longwood Gardens and then another
Korean fire from a private individual so
again this was a really targeted
collection that did result in improved
hardiness and these are now commercially
available so you could you can buy these
from a few mail-order nurseries so
starting in the early 90s our shift our
focus shifted to collecting in China as
you can see here so the 80s really there
was focus on Korea politically things
got easier and so China opened up and
we've really gone on a large number of
trips to China since then we haven't
done this alone we partner as Don say
the partnership called knack peck and
it's been a really great we call it a
consortium because no bylaws there's no
administration it's just a group of
gardens that are committed to this I've
been working together for 25 years to
collect and work with partners in China
so it's been a really great effort so if
you think about China in the United
States they are about the same land mass
roughly large parts of China are have
very similar climates to the United
States so there are a lot of areas that
are easy targets in terms of finding
climatic analog
that work in whether it's southeastern
Pennsylvania or Boston or Chicago so
what we've really targeted are a set of
mountains in central town China the
Qinling mountains which is the
continental divide between the Yangtze
River to the north and the Yellow River
to the south and sorry other way around
Yellow River to the north Yangtze River
to the south and collecting around the
city of Xi'an which is the term one of
the terminus of the Silk Road a very
ancient capital of China and where the
you may know for the terracotta soldiers
and so that area has very similar
climate and great plant diversity so
we've really as you can see targeted the
Qinling mountains both you know from
from east to west so what's it mean to
go to China we have partners and often
will land in Beijing and spend a couple
of days just getting acclimated it's a
12 or 14 hour flight from Chicago to
Beijing so you'd need a little time to
recover from jetlag do a little
sightseeing in some of the you know some
of the historic sites in Beijing do a
little horticultural browsing and or
looking at some of the places this is
pinus bonne Gena at one of the Royal
Palaces in Beijing and then you know go
the Great Wall you're sort of the
touristy things in recent years we've
transited to Xi'an because it's closer
to where we're going Xi'an is a
fascinating place it's really a melting
pot of cultures it's a strong Muslim
influence there and so it's a very
culturally interesting place in China
it's one of the two cities with a with
the remaining wall in China the most
cities in China have the walls city
walls they were torn down during the
Cultural Revolution but the one in Xi'an
was maintained so the interesting
juxtaposition between the modern and the
ancient when you visit a place like this
so from there we then head out and start
to do our collecting in targeted areas
and as I said we owe and last year I was
there in southern Szechuan and visited
kind of again at the beginning of the
trip visited a place that
it's basically the yellow zone of China
long-long Nature Preserve which has
these very interesting travertine pools
a really remarkable place to visit I
traveled the last several years with
another Cornell grad Michael dose Minh
Michael and I have these sort of
strangely parallel lives that have
intersected at many points and so we've
been great friends since the mid 90s and
have traveled in China and are still
friends so Testament something and so
this is again this was last year which
I'll get back to in a minute but a
wonderful place and it's nice to have at
least a day or so to acclimate and just
do a little tourism before you get out
into the field and doing your collecting
so as I said partnerships are really key
for the last 10 years or so we've worked
with the Beijing Botanic Garden on the
right is Kong Wong who works at the
Beijing Botanic Garden has really been
our entree into China and really has
sort of makes it all happen when we're
there but we also then partner with
local botanists in 2005 we worked with
Professor Sun from the lando Botanic
Garden in Gansu Province of Gansu this
past year we worked with the folks at
the long long research station so it's
always good to have a local botanist
this is the someone from Chengdu
Institute of botany and Sichuan who was
with us last year so we'll start out
sort of that we'll set up base and try
and stay there for three or four days
and then radiate out from there so we're
not travelling too much and sometimes
you drive through countryside that looks
like this and you know there doesn't
seem to be a natural plant as far as the
eye can see and you sort of when they're
aware we're something that you know
we're targeted in terms of collecting
and it's this size a couple years old
but you still see this just this
terrorist agriculture it's pretty
remarkable and you really can't get any
machines up there so in some ways it's
like traveling back in time when you
visit these very rural places eventually
you hit the end of the road and then
start hiking up and doing your
collecting so and you know we try and
find these forest cuts where
the seed is actually lower on the plants
we might be able to reach the seed on
the plants so one of the things as I
said that we've been trying to do is
looking at species conservation and
using Botanic Gardens as a model for
species conservation one in terms of
capturing enough diversity that you can
actually do some conservation in the
garden but then also using collecting
unusual and rare species as
demonstrations and educational
opportunities so we've been focusing on
maples
as one of our groups and we're part of
the a PGA's plant collections and
network along with Cornell Botanic
Gardens where one of the multi-site
holders of of maples so the last few
years this has been one of my great
interests and building our collection
we've collected things that look you
know you think of as maples this is Acer
singling ants looks a lot like a sugar
maple then things that don't really look
very maple like that yellow shrubby
plant in the mid ground is Acer stack
via filum which is a high elevation
Chinese species doesn't look very maple
like it's actually related to a suspect
aadum if you know that native species
another one is a syrup Ekta nate 'm
again you know looks somewhat maple like
but kind of stretches what you think of
as a typical maple I mean certainly it's
Samaras give it off here and then a
recent collection is something that
hadn't been in the United States Acer
try caudatum which is related to a soar
plant no DS plant that wasn't in
cultivation in the US and really I think
it's it's best used as a teaching tool
to talk about plant diversity a very
interesting and beautiful plant and then
something you know sometimes you come
across things that are familiar but
perhaps in their native setting don't
seem that familiar so this is a plant
that I've seen not all over but seem
relatively calmly here on campus and we
know what this is dan no this is ASA
grizzly I'm growing in the wild which
you may not think of but you know there
it is growing out
basically out of a rock face here pretty
remarkable
so about 2010 this publication came out
the read list of maples and what's on
the cover a cigar is iam so this was an
epiphany for me I realized at this point
that a sub regime is an endangered
species in China it's a I wouldn't say
common but it's a well-loved garden
plant it's it's really a wonderful
garden plant but in its native habitat
is endangered mostly through habitat
fragmentation and reproduction
reproductive barriers so we started a
project to look at how much genetic
diversity is in kolja Batian and whether
or not that captures the genetic
diversity of plants in the wild or
whether further conservation efforts
need to be made so essentially how many
pandas how many eighths are grisly
misleading in captivity to capture the
genetic diversity of the wild if the
path the pandas or the a surgeries and
where to go extinct so here's the native
range of paper bark maple and this is if
you don't know this plant it's a
wonderful garden plant it has this great
exfoliating bark fabulous fall color and
the plant of many many interests
throughout the year really one of my
favorite garden plants the known
collections the United States only come
from a relatively restricted part of the
range so this kind of in free enforced
our hypothesis that perhaps what's in
Kola Batian is just a fragment or a
segment of the greater diversity so what
we decided to do starting in 2013 was to
sample known wild collected plants in
the United States at these locations and
then folks at the Morton Arboretum start
we're doing the molecular analysis of
these and so if there's any luckier
biologists in here I'm gonna have to
pass on the questions but I sort of know
the general concept so we collected in
the United States and then in 2014
went to England and collected from old
known wild collected trees throughout
England Scotland and Wales and then
here's the National Champion a series
iam in Wales with my friend Chris Bach
tell from the Morton Arboretum in
Chicago
and then in 2015 Chris Bock tell Michael
Kong and I went to China to collect
across the range of ASA grism in China
and taking leaf samples so we traveled
within a 500-mile radius of Chien and
just to give you some perspective we
traveled about 1,600 miles in two weeks
which a 500-mile radius of Philadelphia
or Denver gives you some idea of the
area in which we traveled and so the
topography was probably more like Denver
than it was like Philadelphia and so as
I said here were the known collections
previously in the United States we were
taking leaf samples and wherever we
could seed there's only two places we
saw seed and so we you know we tried to
cover as much of the known range as
possible so comparing the two we really
expanded the range of collections and
just to give you another example of
where we collected so again we we I
think we feel that we've well sampled
the the range there was one population
that we couldn't find but we feel like
we've have a pretty good handle on it so
probably the most impressive tree we saw
was one that a colleague had seen in
1995 this is a tree growing outside of a
village in southern Joshi province and
colleagues of ours had seen this had
made notes and had GPS readings of where
this was so we were able to go back and
look at their notes and go right back to
that place so it really speaks to this
idea of keeping good records and one of
the things about collecting in the field
and being obtained garden is keeping
good records so you know this is a great
testimony that we were able to go right
back to that spot so the Morton
Arboretum doing this work has been able
to construct this molecular tree so the
main thing I want to point out is the
blue centre where it says who Bay Wilson
1901 these are all the plants in
cultivation from the United States and
from England so basically everything
that we've sampled in coloration came
from a collection that eh Wilson made in
1901 so that's what we call a genetic
bottleneck basically everything in
cultivation is one seed collection
supposedly a hundred trees germinated
then but
that's it and you can see in comparison
the other populations that we've sampled
the northern populations in China are on
the top and then the more southerly
populations are on the bottom so from
this data it looks like what we're not
well capturing what's in cultivation
right now there's a there's one missing
piece of this there's a major nursery on
the west coast and Oregon heritage
seedlings that grows something to the
tune of 40,000 ASA Grigio a year and
sells not just grows but cells and we've
sampled those and they're not included
in these so the last question is do they
have anything else that's not shown on
this slide and so once those data are
back we'll have the full picture and
we'll know which populations we need to
target for preservation in China so the
next steps are to work with our Chinese
colleagues to do in situ and ex situ
conservation of some of those more
threatened populations in China so
that's you know this projects been a
really exciting one that's taken about
four years now and it's been a really
gratifying project it's literally taking
me around the world and really been a
fun and interesting project so moving on
talking a little bit about insect and
disease resistance so I living in Ithaca
certainly you know kind of a hemlock
which is you know sort of a wonderful
forest species this is the the most
recent map I could find of the spread of
hemlock woolly adelgid that does seem to
be creeping up into this part of central
New York it's been a problem in
Philadelphia for 25 or more years and
and it basically saps the strength of
the hemlocks to the point where they're
very thin and weak and eventually
succumb to this or they can sort of limp
along with em aequo adelgid but they
really from a ecological point of view
and from an ornamental view they really
lose their value in either in the wild
or in the landscape Chinese hemlock is
appears to be resistant to hemlock
woolly adelgid the adelgid that is the
invasive one is a Japanese insect up
until the mid 90s there was then two
collections of Chinese Hema
and really two trees in the United
States so again a real genetic
bottleneck so if we wanted to look at
increasing the diversity for
hybridization work and for evaluation
work we targeted Chinese hemlock and
have made a number of collections in
central China
since the mid 90s here's Chris Bock tell
with the collection in 2005 and one of
the things we do as I said when we're
doing these collections we make we I'm
still living in the pen and pencil paper
or the pencil and paper world takes you
know scrupulous notes so that you know
people in 20 or 50 years know where we
were
we take herbarium specimens which are
deposited in various herbaria and we
spend our time you know in the nights
and evenings cleaning seed and getting
ready to package the seed and bring it
back to the United States so we
generally collect seed because if you
think about it you know hunger acorns
have a great deal of diversity and
they're really transportable if you try
and bring back 100 oak seedlings it's
it's very very challenging so you see
basically is prepackaged to travel
that's the whole point of seed is
dispersal so it makes our lives a lot
easier and so we are very meticulous
about cleaning and packaging our seed
and making sure we get it in
appropriately and with all you know the
appropriate permits so here we are
packing up at the end of one trip and
then the really exciting part is when
you see them germinate in your
greenhouse these are sugah geneticists
that we collect in 2005 and then growing
on in your greenhouse and then
eventually planted in the landscape so
that's you know the fulfilling part with
some of these collections so we're
actually at the stage with the Chinese
hemlock where we have a number of
collections in the garden we're
evaluating them for horticultural traits
and we're actually working on
propagation both vegetatively and
through seed to try and get some nursery
folks interested in growing this so this
is again a 20 to 25 year process from
inception through propagation and seed
production so it's been you know another
good example of how you know Botanic
Gardens can function so
again talking about insect and disease
resistance you probably all know about
the emerald ash borer I'm not sure how
close it is it's very close to Tompkins
County so it's an insect introduced from
northern China into Detroit
it kills ashes all it seems to be all
native ashes by creating these galleries
in the cambium so it started out in the
Detroit Windsor Canada area and has
spread very quickly and I'll go through
these slides quickly in the last 12
years or so across the northeastern
United States and just keeps spreading
you know it's finally reached
Philadelphia about three or four years
ago and you can see it's it doesn't seem
to have any boundaries or any limits so
far and then the most recent most recent
map is September 2007 and you can see
it's kind of encircling it seems to be
going down the Erie Canal
all right highway 80 no no 80 90 and
then you know inching its way up from
Connecticut as well so as I said it
affects all native ashes American ash
which is you know has a wide native
range and you know wide widely planted
order culturally green ash fraxinus
Pennsylvania has an even wider native
range and if you live in the Dakotas or
in Montana it's one of your primary
street trees even if you live in Chicago
or Detroit so huge economic and
biological impact and so you know this
is sort of the scene you might see in
Michigan this is my wife's cousins
cottage in Michigan so it affects
everybody where it's really having a big
impact it's you know everybody knows
about this not just horticulturists and
these are slides from dan firms at Ohio
State in this is taken in Toledo Ohio
sort of a before and after shot so
they're huge you know implications for
this in many many ways stormwater runoff
heating and cooling costs removal costs
etc etc so and then you know there are
many nurseries that basically had the
terror
they're the nursery stock this is hints
down there 3 a big nursery outside of
Chicago destroying all their ashes about
10 years ago so with this in mind
starting around 2008 we decided to go to
China and collect a diversity of ash
species there was very little Asian ash
in the United States so the idea was to
collect you know expand a number of
species get them in the hands of people
who are doing research on this and look
for any inherent resistance and any
potential for breeding work so we
realized quickly that there are no ash
experts and we became the ash experts
sort of on the fly when we were there
and so we collected starting in 2008 and
going up until the last couple of years
a number of different species and I'll
just touch on a couple of these fraxinus
man Cherica which is essentially the
green ash of China gets to be a large
tree it's a timber tree there there may
be some resistance here so we are
collecting those fraxinus in Solaris is
a medium-sized tree previously not known
in the United States it grows along
stream beds so perhaps might be a good
urban tree and it doesn't get too big so
this this has some potential as a urban
tree here it is growing a green tree on
the left is factionist in solaris and
then another tree fractions china ANSYS
which is sort of a smallish tree but
again this china ANSYS has a very
similar range to the emerald ash borer
so if there is any inherent resistance
track since china ANSYS might have it so
here we are collecting some along a
roadside so those were growing on at the
Arboretum we've gotten them into hands
of researchers in Ohio and in Michigan
who are doing work on this and this is
really a way we can serve as a conduit
to get material into the USDA and into
the Forest Service system so what time
one 10 10 minutes okay
I just want to talk a little bit about
traveling in China because
you know it's part of the whole
experience and it's sort of a immersion
in economic botany in and of itself so
you know this is still you know sort of
what you see when you're there you know
a day in your life traveling in China
and we might you know come across roads
like this or you know something like
this on the highway so I've never been
more terrified than driving in China I
try to tell my wife or show my wife some
of these slides you know so you just
sort of look out the window and hold
your breath when you're in these
situations you see all kinds of crazy
things when you're driving around I'm
not really sure whose idea this was so
you get out and fix the road while
you're there and then as I said you sort
of encounter this you're immersed in a
world of economic botany so this woman
is drawing a - Armand di cones which is
used as a pine nut and widely used as a
nut like - Angeles or the other pine
nuts and then there was a woman cracking
these and boiling he's sort of like
buying boiled peanuts in the south you
buy boiled pine nuts as you're traveling
through this was outside of xi'an and
then another roadside stop as i said was
just sort of this wonderful example of
economic botany in central near xi'an
there's a lot of kiwi productions so
kiwi is really the Chinese gooseberry
it's not you know New Zealand there
started to grow it and call it Kiwi but
it's really native to China so most of
the world's production for juice comes
from this part of China so here's
locally grown Kiwis plums apples two
kinds of walnuts the English walnut and
Chinese walnut on the left chest not so
sort of a whole bounty of locally grown
things growing by the side of the road
and then just sort of experiencing you
know the different architecture and
different aspects of culture is pretty
remarkable there's still a lot of coal
being burned so it won't make any
political comments about that but you
still see coal everywhere this is our
hotel which sort of mimicked the local
architecture and then even being in
cities is pretty fascinating to see the
markets and just see what's going on in
the cities and what goes on on the
street is I think because of a lot of
homes in China are small there's a very
vibrant street life which is really
pretty fascinating here's you can have
your keys made at the local tea maker
there you can have your you know things
mended by the local seamstress out on
the street and so on one of my favorite
shops was the spice shop this was
basically could pick out your blend of
spices for hotpot and they had their
sort of house blend and then you could
pick out and make your own from the
various things that are there and my
favorite shop I love Chili Peppers this
was the local chili pepper shop and you
can see the grinder in the back so I
don't know what it's like to work here
but it certainly was an interesting
place to visit and then you know
wonderful street food as well
this woman has become sort of our
unofficial noodle shop in Xi'an so the
name like tony aiello I've been eating
noodles you know pretty much my whole
life these are you know among the best
bowls of noodles I've ever had and so we
every time we're there we go back and
this is a coal-fired stove scary but
delicious meal and then it's just really
interesting to see hand-pulled noodles
as well and I make my homemade pasta
pretty regularly but I don't do this so
this is pretty amazing but even after a
while you get a little tired of eating
noodles three meals a day so this is
what happens after a couple weeks so I'm
gonna skip a couple skip ahead for one
second just skip through these because I
want to focus on something that we've
done in the u.s. so and I'll wrap up
with this so we have done a fair amount
of collecting in the US and in 2012
again Michael dosa and I had this idea
of collecting live oak quercus Virginia
at the
northern limit of its range because we
had in the whole history of the Morris
Arboretum we've had two plants of live
oak in the 1950s which never made out of
the seedling beds and the Arnold
Arboretum has never had live oak in
their collection so we thought well why
don't we go to the northern limit of the
range both wild populations and
kolevatov plants collect acorns bring
them back grow them on and see if see if
there's any inherent hardiness among
them so and with you know with climate
change perhaps you know this may be a
plan of the future even in Philadelphia
so this slide shows in light green the
native range of live oak and you can see
in far southeastern Virginia one little
bright green county so it does get up
into southeastern Virginia and actually
crosses over into the Delmarva Peninsula
so we made a number of collections as I
said here's another slide showing its
native range the red dots show it in
Virginia we made collections starting in
Richmond and then going down to the
coast in Virginia Beach
so both Michael and I are northern boys
we didn't really know much about Live
Oak but we made a you know a number of
collections this is at a park in
Richmond there's a tree there in the
center which has been there probably for
about 100 years or so and Richmond may
be a tad bit warmer than Philadelphia
but pretty comparable so we thought if
this tree has survived for 100 years in
this park and you know maybe there's
something to it we also collected at
Williamsburg some trees there and then
again as I said in Virginia Beach so
again you know we're taking notes you
know even though we're in cultivated
areas where you know taking notes and
keeping track of what we're collecting
using the same processes again as I said
going down here clicking at William and
Mary and then in Colonial Williamsburg
itself we think these trees were
collected locally and planted there and
they've been there again going on 100
years it's probably a little bit well
it's definitely warmer there than even
in Philadelphia but again just sort of
testing so that provenance and then
finally ending
at the one of the northernmost
populations in Virginia Beach here
Virginia this is a place called first
landing state park a fascinating State
Park it goes from the coast dunal
ecology on the coast to a bald cypress
swamp there are seven ecotypes in this
one State Park a really fascinating
place it's also the northernmost
population of tillandsia Spanish moss
yeah we didn't collect that but we were
tempted to do that and then here you can
see Michael on the right is a live oak
growing on the beach the darker green
and then in this sort of middle to his
left is Quercus in Cana another oak
growing on the dunes so a very obviously
very drought tolerant species and here's
some very old live oaks I don't know how
old these are but they're stolen in
forest so these this organism this plant
is probably 150 years old if not older
so we can't brought them back same kind
of process we've had really good
germination of them and lots of plants
we overwinter them in a somewhat heated
greenhouse and an unheated poly house to
see if there's any effects and then just
last fall you can see some you know in
the spring some leaf damage even at 34
degrees so we threw those plants out and
then here they are again a winter in the
poly house again some damage and so
those plants get tossed planted them out
this past fall so they've had one not
very cold winter in Philadelphia out in
the field they all survived and so we're
waiting to see what happens over the
next couple of winters so we're kind of
in the early stages of evaluations of
these but perhaps in 50 years live oaks
will line the entrance to the Morris
Arboretum instead of magnolias we'll
just have to wait and see
so with that happy to take any questions
in the couple of minutes that we have
left
[Applause]
oh sure any questions from Geneva we're
those purple plums in the market
Europeans or diploid I don't know
of course from Geneva I know and uh I
don't know they look more like Europeans
it could have been yeah they seemed
pretty large and they seemed like what
we when I think of as a plum that we we
get here so I don't think they were any
sort of you know land race or anything
really unusual so Chinese hemlock seems
to have great resistance
I only say total resistance but seems
have great resistance to hemlock wooly
adelgid it does get some of the area
Renea scale but not not on the same
level as as our native hemlock so so and
you know so we've been evaluating it for
25 years
you know actively it really have not
seen any any impact there was some work
done by a graduate student at Yale
looking at this and and as I said that
the woolly adelgid that we have is
Japanese and affects Japanese species
there are woolly adelgid in China that
affect the Chinese species but those
haven't been important to the US right I
think that's a that's interesting and
you know pretty complex question so I I
think you know from a horticultural
point of view I think there's great
potential and that's you know I think
that's pretty obvious I I think it gets
a lot muddier and difficult
more difficult to sort of tease out when
you think about you know whether or not
should use these for naturalization or
for you know reforestation and natural
areas and it's sort of the question with
the with the American chest even though
it's you know fifteen sixteenths or
thirty one thirty Seconds American
chestnut is that truly an American chess
another or not and so I think I think it
my approach has really been more from a
horticultural point of view and I think
when you get into kind of restoration
work it gets a little it gets a lot more
complex yeah so I don't have a good
answer to that other questions any of
the grad students have a question so
probably more at the ceiling growth so
so the question is what do we evaluate
when we look at invasive potential
invasive this so the first thing we look
at is how how it behaves in China or in
the wild wherever we are so and then we
look at how well it germinates in the
greenhouse and if it germinates really
really well we're excited by that
because it's great to have a lot of
seedlings but that you know is also kind
of a warning sign at the same time and
then if you sort of it gets through
those filters so to speak we you know
we'll plant them out in the garden and
wash them and gardeners hate to pull
weeds right so gardeners don't like
weeds so if something starts to seed in
the gardeners at the Arboretum or you
know wherever they are the first sort of
line of people who tell us about that so
I've been you know a few cases where
we've actively had things in the garden
that we've eliminated so it's really
through north of the life cycle as much
as anything so we had collected in 2015
there was a hydrangea aspera that we're
very excited to collect in Sichuan we
brought it back and had you know
incredible seed germination which
very exciting I happened to be in China
again last year in 2016 and saw this
hydrangea everywhere on roadsides
everywhere so that's the kind of thing
that makes you think well okay it's
everywhere so it seems very adaptable it
germinates very readily so maybe we
really need to keep an eye on something
like that
yeah it's yep so the question is you
know you know challenges to getting the
nursery trade to grow super China ANSYS
and and I've had the same experience in
and it's funny we sent cuttings to a
nursery on the west coast who was able
to grow them root them and grow them
really well you know sort of you know
climbing out there is so much better and
produced these these great plants so he
he sent us sort of his dregs of this and
he had I forget how many you know a
couple hundred plants from what the
cuttings we sent him and he didn't know
what to do with them because they you
know on the west coast I don't know
anything about him off woolly adelgid so
he was essentially going to trash these
really nice Chinese hemlock
so I told him don't do that and you'll
hold on to them and I'll find some
nurseries on the East Coast that'll buy
them from you so I think you know it's
it's one of those challenges that are
really hard to overcome and I'm not sure
what it is because I think there there
is a market out there I think I've
caught if a couple people start doing it
maybe it will catch on right there are
some seed sources that you can find and
they germinate easily from seed so you
know I can talk about that who has seed
and I can always always have any said
cuttings to people too so with that I
want to thank Tony
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu